hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines today is about a number of
things but first and foremost I wanted
to make a Sports Complex over here since
I have received a number of comments
about the surprising lack of football
fields in the city and if the city were
to realistically be a Dutch city it
should have many football fields and
that's why I figured this would be the
best place to have a Sports Complex
which is something that you see spread
throughout the city inside as throughout
the Netherlands in cities that there's
one designated area where most of the
sports fields are located and the since
football is the most popular sport most
of these fields will be all about
football just had an American football
field there for a second but figured
that is not quite realistic but aside
from football practice fields I also
figured I could have one athletics field
since that I think in general a
reasonably sized city in the Netherlands
has one athletics field also wanted to
get a couple of tennis courts in there
and some basketball as well
I might get baseball in the future I
didn't quite have it here yet since I
was too lazy to actually get one and I
tend download a baseball field here but
aside from that I think I've got a
reasonably realistic array of sports
over here they'll keep in mind I do plan
on having the real football stadium for
like the cities' Club elsewhere very
close on the other side of the highway
but not quite over here and I'll also
have a swimming pool since Dutch cities
do usually have one swimming pool
planned somewhere in the middle of the
city but that is something that I do not
get in elsewhere as well because the
second thing that I wanted to do in this
episode was to get a small business area
around this part of the city as well and
start work on the train station -
basically this area in general can be
explained in a pretty simple standard
way it's pretty much you have that road
in the middle which is where all the
parking lots are located and which
serves as the main vein to really get
from one place to the other in this
entire sport complex and that's also
where I wanted to place all of the
parking lot spaces and the bicycle lane
as well and then around that I've got
the sport field set up in a grid fashion
since it's just most realistic but also
most efficient when it comes to placing
sports fields and then on the other side
of that road I wanted to get the
business buildings and stuff like that
in the future but that's not going to
quite happen yet but I actually found
out and this is this is very awkward and
I kind of feel bad about this is that I
took a lot of inspiration and I mean a
lot from the Sports Complex where I live
or at least closest to where I live
which even has this central sort of
makeup of one road which serves as the
main transport throughout the Sports
Complex with parking lots attached to it
but what's even worse is that actually
the Sports Complex where I live or in
the town that I live is also tucked in
between the railroad and the highway
just like this one and also has a
business district right next to it and
just like this one will have the futures
so in the end it is awkwardly similar to
where I live but I'm still quite happy
about how it turned out though I
probably shouldn't talk about how it
turned out in the end at this point in
time I also wanted to make sure that I
did get some sort of small garbage
disposal recycling thing over here
realistically I'd want that to be
something which I don't know the English
word of but usually there's a designated
City Council place where you bring your
garbage and they do stuff with it
pile it up and send it elsewhere which
is what I figured that area over there
could be good for but since I don't
think this game really has such a thing
I just placed a couple of recycling
centers over there which is quite
practical as well because I had a
garbage problem and especially when it
comes to services like garbage and fire
houses and police headquarters you need
a couple of that type of building in a
city to actually not get problems with
that in your city gameplay-wise but
realistically you don't have multiple
fire houses within one small medium
sized city or at least not as many as I
would
have over here so that's a bit of a
realism issue as well and now here's the
station which is completely stolen from
Amsterdam by the way and I am 100% sure
that I set this in the real-time footage
as well and I don't start repeating
myself as much as I did in last episodes
but yeah I pretty much went for the
Amsterdam train station since it is
quite large a little bit large for my
liking but the other ones were sort of
too small but it's also the real really
the only dutch station that I could find
and figured that would be the best
reason to get it in here and this will
sort of serve as a entrance over here
where I want to make some fancy Gardens
and also have a very quick small
drop-off point but in a sense this front
of the station will be mostly for
tourists people want to get to the
center of the city since you can very
quickly get to the center of the city
from this front of the station so I
wanted to make sure that this entrance
was a little bit of a nice looking
entrance but not necessarily very
functional and the back of the station
which is incidentally actually how it
works in Amsterdam as well is where my
main bus lines are going to connect to
the station once I get to the bus lines
and it's also where I wanted to have the
parking lot spaces since also
realistically parking lot spaces in the
Netherlands out in the open are pretty
rare and especially when it comes to
parking near a station or parking to get
to the center of the city it's most
likely if you even have large open
parking lot spaces to have them outside
the city so that's why I really wanted
to have the parking lot at the back of
the station over here rather than in the
front since that means I can move it out
from the centre of the city a little bit
more and just figured that would be a
little more a little bit more realistic
and also less ugly in front of the
station though I do have to admit it's a
bit like a palace almost to have these
gardens in front of the station like
that
I mean I do like working on them but it
is a bit too fancy to actually be too
realistic but um oh well I think I like
it too much to get rid of it and over
here is where I wanted to start working
on the business
and we're just because I can I also
decided to get a way to tour
Dutch building in there but it's a Dutch
building and it's it's my favorite
skyscraper in the Netherlands really if
you can even talk about skyscrapers in
the Netherlands but yeah basically this
is the Millennium tower in Rotterdam
it's it's like 140 meters high or 130
probably or 140 plus the spire on top of
it which is cheating but that's how they
can't buildings and yeah it's a little
bit too tall I think for the size of the
city but I really just wanted to get it
in there since it's Dutch and I think
it's a beautiful building and this will
sort of be like the main three large
buildings of the business district and
the rest should really just be more
realistically small scaled office
buildings in a very grid like fashion I
do have to say this is in the end going
to be one of the most grid-like places
in the entire city only other places
where I do want to work with these more
American grids is of course going to be
the port and some other industrial areas
but this should really be a sort of
uniquely large grid area but yeah
basically I moved away from the much
more dynamic road layouts to get to a
more grid like road layout since this
area has both this business district and
the Sports Complex and yeah the rest is
just gonna be boring office buildings
because it needs to be realistic and
that's basically how its set up just
about everywhere I had a lot of trouble
to Kili find some lower buildings over
here so figured well whatever I'll just
actually get some office buildings down
here and really wanted to make sure that
I got some of the lowest ones and wanted
to make sure that I didn't get these
European large old buildings but really
just some low small office buildings and
work with that it's really not going to
be too interesting I already feel like
the buildings that I have right now at
the moment over here are a bit too fancy
for like this the scale of the city in
general but it's I suppose it's a bit of
freedom I wanted to take just because I
like it more but I'm not gonna go any
larger than this when it comes to the
skill of office buildings as much as I
am a fan
of making large economic districts in
city skylines especially and as great as
they can look and as much fun as you can
have with designing infrastructure for
it this is gonna be just about the CBD
of the city and I'm not going to go any
larger than this when it comes to
buildings or office buildings simply
because the scale the city would
realistically allow it so yeah there
will not be any downtown's with
skyscrapers or anything like this this
will be in the main i catching
skyscraper area and then i'll have in
the city but um i just want to focus on
the smaller scale things especially
since the center of the city itself is
going to be the historic center and i
don't mess with that with newer
buildings and i just want to keep it to
a smaller scale anyway this is where the
boring buildings galore really commences
i like one thing that i do have to say
in retrospect is that in real life I
should have arguably made this area a
lot more boring than it currently is
more open spaces and more grass
realistically especially when it comes
to the sports area like I I really had
this tick and honestly I still do to
fill many of the empty areas that I do
leave with ornamental foliage or three
lines or shrubs and bushes and I do have
to say I should keep it down a little
bit more and keep some more open grassy
areas especially around less dense areas
like the sports fields or this office
zone and especially with all the
ornamental tree lines and decorations
like that it looks pretty nice on its
own but once you start to get too many
of them it really becomes too much
detail to realistically have anyway I
just figured this time of system still
going on I collec forgot about this like
normally I actually watch my time lapses
before I commentate over them but this
time I figured I would just do it
randomly but I sort of forgot that I
wanted to make the area with houses over
here and this is actually a pretty big
thing to me and since I've already
recorded episode 9 and 10 I
or eight and nine days I can probably
talk about this this is where I started
experimenting with a Swedish row house
set that I found in the workshop
it's really awesome it it's the
Stockholm row house set and it's got
some Swedish royal houses obviously
which are vastly different from Dutch
row houses but actually found that they
are somewhat similar in terms of style
and use of colors to well touch housing
areas from the 90s onwards the only real
difference is their use of textures they
use really Dutch houses really have this
very sterile took very typical brick
texture and these Swedish houses don't
have that or don't have that they seem
to have a stucco type of texture which
is something that does bother me a
little bit but I figured you know
whatever these swedish houses might
actually be very good if I wanted to
make some 90s and zeroes Phoenix
neighborhoods as they call them which
are more widely set up with a lot of
parks not as much foliage as older
neighborhoods and actually a lot of fun
with the road types as well and this is
sort of where I tried to experiment with
these house types and figured that they
actually really really [ __ ] good and
I want to work with them more in the
future so this was sort of like a
turning point in how I wanted to make
this city and with that I should
probably say that I'll use the Swedish
houses a bit more in the future but I
also want to start removing the old
neighborhoods that I have in the city
especially the one that is right next to
where I'm building right now is one that
I do in a remove in favour of these
houses and in favor of a much more fun
to build but also fun to look at
layouts as well since going for 90s and
later houses in the Netherlands also
means that you have a lot more freedom
and what you do in roads there's barely
any rules anymore to what you do with
your Road patterns it's not like you
have to specifically set up straight
roads or go with Cola flowers and you
can actually have a lot of fun with
geometric shapes as well with this type
of neighborhood and it also helps a lot
since what I've probably commented about
a little while ago is
and all of the houses in my city looked
exactly the same which is something that
I couldn't get around but now that I
have the Swedish houses there is
actually quite a number of row houses
that I can try to get in at different
places and actually get in variation of
different houses so yeah I do want to
transform the city to a little bit more
of a modern style which means that I'll
be demolishing all parts and that'll be
bye-bye my old work but hopefully the
city will improve in general anyway last
couple of comments about this area this
is a very new area so I did want to keep
the foliage small although I probably
talked about that in the real-time
footage as well and it's very it has
very wide set up house is a reasonably
far apart and there's a lot of space and
a lot of parks for the houses as well
and playgrounds and things like that
basically in the modern philosophy of
your open living and comfortable houses
in general but not too anonymous anyway
I'll leave it to the real-time footage
now all right so here's the current
state of things the I think these ports
area is sort of finished there's a
number of problems that I still have
with it this should be the overall thing
one of the things which kind of annoy me
about it is how much concrete there is
everywhere I'd rather just have this
thing be a number of practice football
fields and stuff like that I can't
really do that since pretty much all of
the football fields that I found were
either too small or they were large
enough but come with this concrete path
next to it and even these like stadium
seating many things I don't know what
you would call them but like best
scenario that this would have all been
like practice fields and I might come
back to it at some point in the future
if I do find football fields that I can
use for that type of thing but for now
otherwise I do kind of like it it's just
a little bit close to what I wanted to
have over here as the small office slash
economic district with a couple of new
buildings over here which is pretty much
ripped off from the town where I live
where you also have this little field of
some office buildings and things like
that very close by the sports fields and
all that stuff and then over here is
also the train station which is very
very closeby kind of would have liked it
to be a little bit further away from the
edge of the city really because now it's
almost at the edge of the city but
there's not really too much I can do
about it
this is just sort of the situation and I
figured I wanted to have a small almost
a central business district but I don't
think I can really talk about that
reason being that I wanted to get the
melon millennium Tower in since it's a
building from Rotterdam and I just
needed to get that in so sort of the
business district revolves around that
and it's just a small little space with
offices and things like that and over
here I would have some houses in the
future also these the train station
itself is from Amsterdam which is a
little bit large I think for this scale
of a city because the city is not going
to be too much larger but I just figured
this being like the most Dutch train
station that I could have I would use
this one and much like Amsterdam kind of
have a cool looking entrance with paths
and have the future bus thing and
parking lot at the back of it so that's
how that sort of works over here and one
new thing which I'm actually really
happy about was that I wanted to try to
make a new neighborhood like a very new
like built in 2015 and the trees haven't
even grown yet where you find the same
sort of style of streets as these but
with a little bit more curves in there
and different types of houses now I got
a pact with Swedish houses and with some
upgrade limitations like that I can get
just some different houses in specific
places where I want them and I'm
actually really happy about the way it
looks it's very very reminiscent of the
modern Dutch neighborhoods that I just
built where it's just grass and just a
couple of people lived there so far and
the rest still has to grow the only
problem that I have with this area is
that I kind of wanted to have this a
hill of grass be a little bit more steep
but Hills already start becoming Rocky
very soon like if you just
very gentle slope you already get those
rocks on the side and I wish that I
could just make this a grass hill just
to make sure you don't have the sound
from the highway so I think in the end
I'll just put a small or maybe some
foliage on top of this hill and see how
that would work but there's being a very
new neighborhood I can't really afford
to place any large trees around it
simply because this is so incredibly new
but yeah I'm actually really happy about
it and would like to try this type of
neighborhood maybe more often in the
future this was really just a test but I
think it's actually the best one of the
best sort of places are built in here
but yeah that's it for today so thank
you guys for watching and next time I
think I'll finish up this bit over here
which I don't know some sort of
neighborhood with row houses I think I
might also want to get some detached
houses over there and other stuff that I
want to do is come up with a way to
maybe fill this in and perhaps start
filling this in with the stadium things
like that or make some more farms over
here whatever I feel like I suppose so
see you guys next time